Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I am checking in on you.
Um,
you know I do this show.
I usually,
you know how I do,
I usually uh,
talk here to myself.
I usually babble.
I usually ramble and then I try to read out loud but every once in a while I
have a special guest and a,
this is one of these Thursdays.
Um,
this man is here to promote his new book.
Everybody is awful except for you.
That will be uh,
you can preorder now and it's going to be available on Amazon,
Barnes and nobles and all that stuff.
Please welcome Jim Florentine.
Everybody.
It's good to see you bill and thanks for having me back man.
He liked how I did the big buildup.
I said the book,
I did the whole thing.
I was waiting for everybody to sit back and try and guess who the hell it was
going to be,
you know,
and then,
then I,
then I dropped the name on it.
That's old school shop is right there.
That is cause then like who could it be?
Maybe it's,
you know,
someone hasn't talked a while.
Maybe he's getting a Louis C K exclusive,
maybe Louise coming back.
Yeah.
Maybe he's coming back and he's going to do what?
I'm bill's podcasts and you know,
we were just talking about that.
He might as well dive in.
That whole me too thing.
It's just like obviously it had to happen and everything,
but it is such like a bullying environment.
Even like the bullshit one,
if it's a bullshit one,
you can't say anything.
Like recently one came out,
it was just like,
all right,
this just seemed like this woman wanted a famous boyfriend and it didn't happen
and then the end she went on her friend's blog or some shit and trash this guy,
and I can't even name names before all these fucking lunatic start coming at
like,
there's no,
there's no like,
hey,
let's,
let's examine this.
It's just all this person said that that means that's how it happened.
That's how the whole thing went down.
And let's burn down this person's life and their entire bill ability to earn a
living is a little nuts.
Absolutely.
And be me being a single guy out there.
You don't know.
You do like sign in triplicate before you'd be like,
I'm trying,
I'm trying to get like,
you know,
shacks contract.
He used to sign or Michael Jordan or whatever.
It's supposedly I had a thing where they would sign like they're Osisko Cisco.
Okay,
you go into the hotel room next door,
you know what's going to happen?
Sign here.
Yes,
this,
this is so here's a consent.
You're good.
Center water and then you know what you're going in there and you guys are going
to have sex and that's it.
What about funding?
One of the funniest things that I've read as far as like just all this extreme
mindset that's out there about politics that's out there,
about,
about this me to set everything is just,
you have to be like all the way on the left side of the room against the wall or
all the way on.
The other one is um,
oh God dude,
I'm getting so old.
I literally forgot my point right in the middle of it.
I swear to God I was going to make the greatest point.
I literally just fucking,
what the fuck was it?
Oh,
I know.
This is going to be a lot of this by the way.
Uh,
uh,
coercion is not consent is what they said.
When you coerced into doing something that is not consent.
So that I was thinking like,
okay,
that mean I don't have to pay
my bank loan this fucking month on my,
on my,
my car loan and a body.
You don't want this man.
You want the turbo man.
You come around the corner,
they hear and that engine,
the whole fucking world is coercion.
Everybody,
our whole business,
everything you,
anytime you sell anything,
any of it.
Half the Shit my wife does to me,
dude.
If coercion is not consent in women actually stuck by that,
would brunch still exist?
And that's a good point.
No Guy,
if you actually could see you want to go to that?
No,
I do not.
And then she can be like,
well I'm all mine.
That's coercion.
Like,
cause you immediately,
you're like,
yeah,
oh fuck.
I don't want her to cry.
Anytime a guy goes to bronch,
he's taken the bullet on something.
Oh my words.
The worst is when they come up,
they said it's going to be like 40 minutes.
Is that going to be,
can you still stand like you have the option to say no.
I mean,
I say no.
That's why I fight with my wife so much.
No,
let's get outta here.
Yeah,
we can.
I can.
I can literally Google how to make fucking,
no pun intended.
Eggs Florentine.
Go to the supermind.
It's eggs and steam.
Fucking spinach on an English muffin.
I can figure this out.
No,
but I just as a fun audience here,
so look,
obviously it's great that there's a form now that all,
all these,
these,
these are some of the shit this guy's did.
Like who the fuck knew people did that?
I mean,
I knew that it was fucking creeps out there,
but like now it's just getting,
it's getting to the point,
but with not,
it's not getting to the point,
but there's been a few where there's a few things where it's like you couldn't
handle that amongst yourselves.
Like did I need to know all the gory details of what you guys did here?
And then there's other ones that are just complete bullshit,
but I,
I still don't feel that we're at a place where you can actually say that because
I think if you do,
then then what?
Then you're a rapist.
Yeah.
Then yeah,
absolutely.
You can donate it and you'll understand.
The women now,
they just said,
we just want the guys to listen.
We don't want them to respond.
Don't come back like you're in a relationship and when your girls complain about
something on the wall,
I know how to fix it.
Listen,
that makes sense.
If what they're saying is true.
Yeah,
exactly know if you,
but if you're telling a fucking,
if you,
if you're talking about apples and you say in their oranges and then you're
telling me I'm supposed to shut the fuck up and then watch somebody I know lose
their fucking life,
their career,
that doesn't make sense either.
And I feel like a lot of people feel that and everyone's choosing like self
preservation,
like,
sorry,
I keep hitting the table here.
Like,
uh,
like the Golden Globes,
right when you went to that,
it's like,
dude,
if you didn't have a black shirt underneath you Tuxedo,
I mean you,
you,
you were finished.
That meant you advocated sexual assault that night.
Then you had a word of pin.
Okay.
Time's up thing.
But here's the thing,
you literally could have just sexually assaulted somebody but wore a black shirt
and had the pen and no one would fuck with you.
Right.
So I don't eat,
I don't,
I'm old.
I,
so I don't,
I don't get what's going on anymore.
I don't get it.
Sorry man.
You're here to sell a book.
No,
no,
no.
I'm only getting
to know,
I do want to get into it.
No,
absolutely.
I mean there's the story that we're talking about is just insane.
You know,
it was it,
there was oral sex performed bolt time two times on each,
on each other.
And then when he wanted to have intercourse,
she,
she's like,
Nah,
I don't know.
And he's like,
all right,
we'll hang or whatever like that.
And then he had a funny line.
No,
I thought it was a funny joke.
So he goes,
come on,
let's just have intercourse cause everybody would do.
And she goes,
you know what,
I,
I'd rather wait for the second day for that.
And he was at his place and he goes,
so if I pour you a new glass of wine,
is that considered a second day?
That's a fucking funny line.
And a guys throwing it out there,
it's a desperate Lonnie,
it is funny.
And then she goes,
no,
and then,
and then they hung out for a little longer and she goes,
I'm just going to go home.
She wasn't upset.
He goes,
okay,
I'll get you a car service center in a car.
Text her the next day.
He had a good time.
He last night.
Well I did.
And,
and then that's how it started.
Some of these,
these,
these uh,
what do you call him?
The cougars after a show.
Like if you will,
if you go out and you're selling anything,
dude,
you got to get manhandled when you're out there warming.
Handled fucking once a weekend.
It happens to me cause I sell merchandise after a show.
Once a weekend.
Yeah.
Grab my ass.
Literally something.
If you did it like over po Po,
put your hand on my wife's tit.
No,
it's okay.
Or a girl goes,
hey,
put it on my tits.
Come on.
It'll be funny.
Or every time.
All the time.
You got to come out after a show.
Now you don't go.
Those guys wear that suit.
What?
You fucking dismantle a bomb.
You've got to come a gap thing all made a lit.
Well tell me,
tell me what is the book about?
Cause I already like,
I love the title.
It's everybody.
Everybody is awful.
And then parentheses except you to like how I heard that was everybody,
you know,
on Facebook going on and on about how great they are and like how the world's so
awful and you know,
I don't know,
just having the whole Selfie,
the selfie generation.
Yeah.
That's basically what it is.
It just calling people out bad Facebook posts,
you know,
people brag and people looking for attention,
to,
you know,
to PR person that posts so and uh,
among my weight at a hospital and they just leave it at that.
I go,
okay,
so now you're going to get 50,
what's wrong?
Are you okay if I lived in New Jersey,
I'd beat air for you,
but I can cute.
Please keep us updated.
Is Everything okay?
And then at the end it was just a sore throat.
Oh yeah.
You know what I mean?
It's never,
you always figure out these,
these,
these things like this crank Yankers all the way to this.
You always fun terrorizing telemarketers.
You always find like that,
that thing that people are like,
I don't know.
It's,
I always see whenever you do a project,
I was thinking it was right fucking there was hanging right there and you just,
you up like this.
You've done the um,
the uh,
uh,
what was supposed to show on VH one.
I just went blind.
That metal show metal shell.
Yeah.
How did you know that there was going to be in awe?
Like there was a bunch of people like me who wanted to know what Bobby blots or
was doing.
I would like,
I was so excited to see all those guys.
Like there was such a huge part of my life and a,
you know,
a part of my life,
is you were a teenager.
He's a drama for rat by the way.
And it has a Pete just being a teenager where
there's sort of all of this exciting stuff and then all of this scary and
depressing shit all happening at the same time and that music was so great and
so fun that like,
I mean all of those guys in those,
those bands to me are on the same level of like the fonts were like when I was a
really little kid,
like the Fonz,
they had the trading cards and they're like,
literally you're looking at somebody like made my childhood happier.
When I watched your show,
that metal show,
I was like,
oh my God,
I fucking love that guy.
Like what?
What is,
uh,
is it just how your brain works?
Like how do you always seem to,
to,
to find,
I don't know.
I think we just got under the good time VH one classic was like looking for a
one original program that didn't have anything on it.
Just show him repeats of just old music videos.
And we pitched like a heavy metal talk show.
I liked the tonight show for ACDC fans.
They said,
okay,
we'll give you money.
For one pilot.
We pulled Lita Ford out her retirement.
She was,
didn't do anything for like 20 years.
She was living in an island,
raising her kids.
So we had her as a pilot episode where like,
all right,
it doesn't know why she's back on the road.
She never sees her kids.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Great moms.
She was being a great mom until we gave her exposure.
It's like,
oh damn,
I got a career.
And next thing he knows he's put three albums out in the last nine years.
Oh,
that's awesome.
And then,
uh,
you know,
and luckily the head of like VH one classic,
this guy used to be a d,
like a metal DJ up in Buffalo.
He goes,
I love this show.
Put It on the air.
You know,
it's going to be a shitty bar budget.
And I remember my manager goes,
this is the worst contract I've ever seen in my life.
You sure you want to sign us?
Like go,
yeah,
like whatever.
Who Cares?
At least we'll be on the air.
And we did 140 episodes,
w seven seasons.
Who is some of your favorites?
Cause I knew that you were kind of already in that world a little bit like a lot
of you guys like you Norton and all those guys,
big Jay,
you guys seem to like know brewer.
Brewer.
Yeah.
Guys seem to build the know like rock stars and stuff like that.
You were kind of already in that world,
but when you went there,
what was like your bucket list of guests and were you able to get most of them?
Yeah,
I mean Tony Iommi,
you know,
we got bottler,
Ronnie James Dio before he passed away was on twice.
Then we get Marilyn Manson,
you know,
we got Tom Morello from rage against the machine and I'm a huge fan.
We had Steve Harris from iron maiden,
so every,
every season with somebody different,
like you gotta be kidding.
Sammy Hagar,
Michael Anthony.
You know what I loved about Steve Harris was even people who had none,
knew nothing about music will be like,
that guy's an unbelievable bass player.
Yeah,
he was,
yeah,
his fingers just flying.
Um,
actually iron maiden was the one that when I first wanted to play drums,
it was their drum.
Nicko mcbrain that was one of those,
uh,
one of those screen from a long beach,
you know,
that they filmed or whatever.
And uh,
I just remember when they finally went behind them because you should always see
the arms moving.
Yeah.
You can never see me.
He's buried in the sand.
When I saw the legs moving,
I was like,
that looks fucking cool.
And I already failed on guitar because he actually had to like no notes and shit
like that.
And just coming from more of a sports background as that guy,
he just kind of beat the shit
I know.
After,
after that looks like fun after a,
you know,
a big patriot loss,
you can no problem pounding the,
Oh,
speaking of which hat,
what are you,
I know you're a,
an,
there's a famous story about you.
You're a huge Miami Dolphin Fan.
There's this story that Keith Robinson is told me probably a dozen times and I
never stopped them because I love it was you were on a,
you're on some flight watching a dolphin game and that you will,
you will going,
please tell me it's true,
right.
The will landing and the stewardess told you to shut your phone off or whatever
you were watching you you've refused to because it was an important part.
It's like this is before cell phones.
I have one of those little TVs with the antenna,
you know,
it's a little box and it was a play.
It was a dolphins and Bobby Kelly can find the next thing.
He always had that shit.
This was like an,
I don't know,
probably 99 it was [inaudible] 98 when Montana was on the chiefs Dolphin chief
playoff game and I was talking to on a fly from Florida and it was on like the
local ABC cause there's a playoff game,
right.
So I had one of those little old school TVs when an antenna and I watched it
under a blanket the whole game.
Cause I didn't have to switch like a moment where in South Carolina I got to
find the ABC affiliate there.
And then when I'm on and I'm switching around like this and I'm,
and Baltimore,
I got to find the other church,
I feel.
So I watched a whole game and the woman came over like 20 minutes left.
You have a TV on,
shut that off.
It's gonna affect the plane.
I got too bad.
I go,
it's,
it's 2121 and Merinos drive and with two minutes left,
she goes,
you've got a shot.
Like go,
I'm not shutting it off.
I don't care.
And even when the plane landed,
I still watching the whole thing and they won like right as the plane landed.
I'm like,
yes.
Oh that's why it was pre nine 11 it was pre nine 11 and I had that little,
yeah.
And you couldn't have any,
any kind of electronic device on the plane,
you know.
But I'm saying if now if you said no,
Oh yeah,
that would have been like,
you know,
like the CIA absolutely would come on and fucking were waiting for me when I
liked it.
But yeah,
I would not shut the TV off on the note.
I will add it on the black.
I didn't get caught to like 20 minutes left in the flight.
I watched the whole game.
My girlfriend at the time,
we sit next to me.
I was screaming.
She was miserable.
She was the way to end a bad trip on my head to bad breaking over again.
Anyway,
when I get back,
oh,
I didn't know.
I thought you wanted like a jet blue because I was thinking,
well why wouldn't they just shut the thing on God,
your rowing team and my own little TV.
I brought it just in case they go to,
I was already doing the math.
I'm like,
if they win,
they're going to play on Saturday at four 30 my,
that's when my flight is,
so I'm bringing my TV just the case and that's exactly what happened.
Wow.
Do you know when the,
when the Patriots beat Seattle?
I was flying from Sydney,
Australia to like Auckland,
New Zealand and I missed the whole game cause I was thinking that it's the
Superbowl they showed around the world,
they're going to have it on,
like,
you know,
they had TVs,
all they had was soccer.
I was like,
you gotta be kidding me.
So when I got off the plane,
I knew it was towards the end of the game,
but I just had to know.
So I told,
I asked my wife,
I go,
uh,
what's the score?
And she's like,
Oh,
I'm says the Patriots are winning.
And I was like,
really?
You know,
cause I was still,
you know,
after those two giant losses,
I was like,
Oh God,
now he's going to be three and three,
you know,
and um,
I go,
how much time's left?
And she's like,
um,
it's says it's over.
I go,
no way.
Don't wait.
And then it looked,
I was like,
fuck.
It started screaming in the middle of New Zealand,
look like a maniac.
And then it went back to the hotel.
And they would just showing the Superbowl in this weird channel with no
commercials.
And I watched it twice back to back.
And then I watched it again the next morning and I couldn't,
like,
I had no idea about that whole play in the end or anything like that.
But,
uh,
um,
anyways,
getting back to the initial thing I was going to ask you,
um,
a lot of people,
you know,
are talking about the Jaguars and the defense,
and uh,
they going into New England,
you know,
nobody thought that they were going to go into Pittsburgh.
Well,
some people did,
but they went in there,
they won there,
they beat buffalo bills,
but they beat the bills and it was like this snooze fest.
And then,
you know,
they went into,
uh,
the Steelers and they had like a shootout.
So everybody's talking about how great their defenses,
and I'm still like,
they just gave up like 40,
41 points,
but the week before,
who the fuck are they?
So Jim Florentine,
Amanda brought a TV on a fucking plane in 1999.
What is your gut feeling?
Uh,
patriots or a
patriots.
Absolutely.
You,
you don't win in Foxborough and you know,
and Patriots Gillette Stadium,
you don't win.
They're a championship game.
You think Bella checks the seals were looking past the Jaguars waiting for the
championship game.
We're fucking dude's always do it.
We came out,
we played them.
They had already,
they had already bought their fucking plane.
Like that's the,
you know the urban myth.
They've had already bought the plane tickets and hotel reservations down in New
Orleans.
Um,
that,
yeah.
Well you got bet Bella check to prepare for Blake Bortles.
They've got no shot.
Yeah,
I don't care what kind of defense they're running back there running back got
hurt too.
Yeah,
with that defense looks good but to do,
but that's all right.
Birdie will pick them apart.
So find somebody last week they did not like some guy will come off the practice
squad tomorrow and Oh,
catch 10 passes on Sunday.
Here's the thing,
how long can we do this?
We just keep doing it and do,
he doesn't have a number one.
This isn't it.
We don't even know
number one receiver right now.
I'm with Edelman being out the whole year and uh,
you know,
I know we got Gronk he's a tight end but like are,
are,
you know
there's a lot of passes.
They,
I dunno.
No it's that one guy he fucking stops.
It's like keep running,
keep letting it and lot of times I see Brady go and like just keep fucking
running.
So I dunno like this,
this game scares me.
This game scares me cause they can do the whole fat diet jacked up till then I
suppose to pay here.
I got nothing to lose.
But Baba Baba Baba,
I'm getting all nervous about that now.
I think that they had their run,
I mean they pay,
if the bills had any kind of quarterback they should have won that game.
The first playoff game and Pittsburgh was waiting for New England.
They overlooked it.
There weren't prepared.
You sorta first quarter,
they weren't even,
but you know the head was in a different game.
Patriots.
The only problem they could have is maybe if they play Minnesota in Minnesota
because the game will be a home game.
I was nervous about it.
It's like the saints.
Like I called that saints game.
I called and I was like,
drew Brees is going to go in there.
He gets no respect.
He's like the third all time and all that shit.
He's going to go in there and I kept saying that,
you know,
all these Minnesota fans,
we're going to go to the mall of America going to the giant clean next door and
they were going to be crying and everything and exactly what the fuck I said was
going to happen until that last play with 14 seconds left,
which I have never ever in the history of watching people fuck up.
I have never seen anybody do what that poor kid did.
It's like he put his head down and stop looking at the guy and then he throws,
he basically threw a block,
took out his own fucking guy.
It's just,
I've never,
I still cannot fucking believe that that happened.
We um,
I was watching a game,
a bunch of friends of ours at 17,
nothing halftime and my brother gambles.
He's like,
all right,
look,
there's 10 to one odds you want to put on on the saints,
come back and win this game.
So we put um,
like $2,000 in a pot,
so I would have 1-800-BUCKS-IF they were to just made a typo right there and
spread was five,
right?
The scribe was five,
but we had to just sort of sayings to win the game from the second half.
They were down 70 nothing and a half time I go,
I'll do that.
So they had to win the half of win the game when the whole game at 17.
Nothing.
I'm like,
I'll put eight oh eight 80 bucks in,
I would've won 800 bucks and I'm watching it.
We're all,
can you guys doing?
We're like,
yes.
That was just,
all right,
good.
We've got this or you owe this and right now I'm only down this and this and
then we're watching the last play.
Like
I was picturing all you guys walking and talking to the narrow with buying your
wives furs and stuff.
When I say what I say,
don't buy anything.
Don't take it back.
Oh my God,
that's fucking do I wish you guys had the reaction video or that you guys just
talking about all this shit?
I was already crossing off my battery on my God.
Cool.
I'm only down 30 for the day.
This you took this and we're just already figuring out like,
we got this.
That's one of those games.
I immediately went to youtube to see people's reactions to it and these fucking
nerds were like the first people that put theirs up and it was the worst
reaction ever.
They're like,
oh my God.
Wow.
That's crazy.
And they already monetized it and everything else I fucking mad at him.
I want him to see st spans crying and Viking fans crying because I figured like
the best reaction video I ever saw was when,
when Auburn,
my favorite one,
I went to Auburn caught that,
that field goal that came up short against Alabama and the dude ran the whole
thing back like Alabama was kicking to,
uh,
to win the game and it was a long field goal.
And if they missed,
who gives a shit?
We go into overtime.
I believe that was the scenario and it came up short and you can return it in.
The Auburn Guy fucking caught it and I,
they caught him sleeping and he ran it like a 105 yards back.
And my favorite one was these two girls.
One was for Auburn,
one was for Alabama,
and the one screaming co,
the other ones like freaking out.
And then the end,
the fucking Auburn girl looks to the Alabama girl who was just totally stunned.
She's like,
y'all just lost
fucking great.
So,
um,
anyways,
I keep forgetting to talk about the book.
So,
um,
you can preorder
this thing.
Wait,
where are they going?
Are they going to iTunes?
They go to I book.
What do you,
where do you go to Amazon?
Just,
it's all the links up on Amazon.
Oh,
the link is up on Amazon.
It's Jim Florentine.
Everybody's awful except you are,
comes out February 20.
It's just me.
It's basically based off my podcast where I just,
you know,
people send in like bad Facebook posts or like vanity plates,
awful vanity.
This is some of this stuff.
Bed of Hennessy pussy power wash,
awful Facebook rule number 10,
drown us and dumb ass details.
Oh,
this is fucking great.
And I,
these are actual Facebook posts by people are posted.
And then I just,
you know,
just take,
take him down,
you know.
Oh my God.
The weather posts in Ohio,
you know,
Mother Nature,
go away.
Okay.
Do you know what's funny is earlier this year I went to this fucking award show,
uh,
in one of these ones that was not televised.
That's the level that I'm at in this business.
Right?
So I had a friend of mine,
he's got,
hey man,
this is going to be like this big fucking thing,
blah,
blah.
You know,
so eventually maybe it'll be a big award show,
you know,
if you want to go.
My wife loves music and he had a double date flub lesson.
All right,
let's go.
So right before,
what kind of go the other couple has to cancer cause simple shifts and I would
go into this fucking thing that I,
you know,
I'm like God,
Jesus Christ.
So we show up dude.
I swear to God,
every fucking person say say 20 people want awards that night 19 people cried
and talked about how hard it was and everything they went through and blah,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
And I was just sitting there.
I just wanted to yell out,
you're in your 20s
how hard can you,
10 years ago you were in high school,
you're accepting a fucking award and you got to hit album.
How fucking hard could,
how could it have been?
I was like almost 20 years.
It's still on a fucking Futon,
right?
Nothing.
I Dunno.
I was paying,
my bills would change at 36 years old.
Oh Jesus.
Taking it down.
That a change thing at the supermarket,
you know like they take like 8 cents off a dollar.
That was paying a 36 yeah.
He's a thing like who gives a fuck?
Like,
I don't know,
like I don't know.
The entertainment business is difficult.
Like is it easy for somebody else?
Nobody goes into this business.
Even if you make it in two seconds,
then all that means is you're going to get fucking slammed back down to the
ground because when you start to dip,
you're not going to know how to handle it and you're going to fucking freak out.
It's better to get punched in the face repeatedly as you're walking up the hill,
other than to just be on the chair lift,
go right up to the top and the first time you'll drop a ski or something like
that,
all that,
you're just gonna go right down the other side of the mountain.
So I actually,
it was one of the few times where I was semi ruining something.
Did your wife know you were annoyed?
Yeah,
but she thought it was funny.
She did.
I didn't think it was funny because right from right in the beginning it was
annoying.
I got there in this like I'm standing there,
you know the panic,
you know when you,
you get like you're on like the guest list and you know they're going to your
name
and the like,
I don't see it.
Then they found it.
I was like,
I had like this relief and all of a sudden the security guys just like,
excuse me Sir sir,
I'm going to need you to clear this and we need to clear it and I'm thinking
like I'm in this totally open area.
This woman had to fucking walk by.
It was just like some,
I dunno,
I dunno who the fuck it was,
but like she literally had 10 feet on either side of us and the guy was still
telling me I had needed to get further up.
It gets like,
do you want me to become part of the paint?
I don't know.
So sorry.
This is just podcast is becoming about me complaining.
No,
no,
no.
That's perfect.
That's what I should say.
I don't know.
Every once in a while I want to have a guest and I tried to want to like lighten
it up or something.
How is the,
uh,
want to lighten it up?
Okay.
How's,
how's The New York comedy scene?
It's great.
It's been,
if you've been,
uh,
you know,
I moved away,
believe it or not,
like over 10 years ago.
So when I go back now,
I don't know who a lot of the new people are all,
all of the,
uh,
there's a ton of them yeah.
As it should be.
And a good,
you know,
the good,
the,
it's thriving men has all the clubs,
they're packed.
And I really liked to stand the stand is my club in the city and his great love
that place.
And there's,
there's a danger fields I still love.
I haven't walked in there in 15 years.
And then the New York Comedy Club,
uh,
Al doesn't own it anymore,
so it's gotten better.
It's actually a decent gig.
And then they got the village on the ground.
It's like the comedy cellar and they got like three or three like they did when
I was in New York.
The seller had the cellar,
they had,
uh,
the y I don't think they had the village is at village underground.
I don't think they had that.
No,
he had like,
yeah,
they're like,
like playing monopoly.
Like they keep it,
they got three rooms that you like 10 shows on a Saturday night.
It's incredible.
I remember I used to be so jealous of,
uh,
when I was living with Bobby Kelly.
Um,
we both have nine shows,
but I would be all over the city and he would,
he would have three at the Boston,
three at the Wa three at the cellar and he didn't have to take one cab.
He could just walk to all of them and he,
you know,
you got paid 50 bucks a seat.
So he,
he'd have nine fifties and I'd have a bunch of twenties and fives.
I'll smash together from jumping in cabs going from the strip down to the cellar
backup to stand up New York.
Um,
can you do that anymore?
I know they kind of switched the way they,
some of those guys.
Yeah.
You could still do what it's.
Um,
I,
I try to stay like one club,
one or two maybe in New York comedy club to stand.
I don't feel like running around,
like rushing around.
You know,
I'm not,
I'm not my twenties anymore.
I'm just jumping on,
start doing this,
running into another sec,
hold back over here.
I'm like,
oh good.
You know what I mean?
I'm working on my shit.
I know what I need to do.
I'm like,
sometimes they look just like the staying the same.
It's like I'll do three shows.
I did New Year's Eve,
I did four shows at the stand to stay there all night.
Oh,
that's perfect.
Other than the only time it sucks is when they were in between shows and it gets
a little pack.
But then like they put them downstairs and you're fine.
Yeah.
What do you,
uh,
how much standup do you do with all these like TV shows and books and all that
type?
How often do you get to get two weekends?
I'm on road two weekends a month.
Oh,
that's good.
Yeah.
And I do a one weekend in New York and then I take one weekend off.
So I got my son one weekend a month alone also during the week to how old you
saw now?
Seven.
That's amazing.
He's already getting into stand that he's been on stage like five times and he
plays like from you.
You're like racing like the coolest kid ever.
I'm saying.
And now,
now he's all about stand up now because I took them out.
Uh,
there was a show that Ronnie be,
Bennington does a show,
his radio show at the hard rock in New York every year does a live show.
There's 400 people.
It's sold out.
And he did a segment where you go,
oh,
comedians go up and tell an old joke.
So I brought my son with me and he goes,
look,
if you want to go on stage,
you could tell an old joke is okay,
I will.
And he went up there.
I introduced him to place,
went nuts.
He grabs the mic and I didn't even tell him.
I said,
he goes,
Oh,
you guys ready to hear a funny joke?
And I'm like,
man,
he's already working in a crowded place cause not something as a host.
I know what he tells a joke and to play and it gets an applause break and he's
up there and eat and we sit up on stage for another 10 minutes.
He felt that.
Ever since then he's like,
dad got a show tonight.
Come on,
go get a show.
Let's just go get a show.
Just you more on stage,
right?
You can go down to the club.
I go,
yeah,
I could come on.
We've got to do.
Which one are we doing?
A show,
you know it's gonna be funny is that when he has to do like a book report about
nervous,
she would get,
he's going to be like all amped up to do what?
He's going to be psyched.
When I was in school,
I would just be like,
I would be so scared and she wouldn't call it,
the teacher wouldn't call on me.
It'd be like,
thank God.
And then I see my buddy go up and then when he'd be done I'd be like,
Oh fuck,
I wish I was him because it would be over.
And,
uh,
I had like a horrible,
I had horrible fucking,
uh,
I guess was that stage fright?
I would public speak and yeah.
I mean,
once I knew I wanted to do comedy,
it took me a year to get onstage.
You get the balls to get on stage because I was petrified.
That's what I did.
I gave myself a,
I made a new year's resolution in 1992.
I was like,
at some point in this year,
I gave myself a whole year to do.
It was funny,
but the second I did it,
uh,
all of a sudden it was a talent contest,
like in January and I just signed up for it.
And,
uh,
it was like a month out and then there was so many guys,
they pushed it.
And so I started like right in the beginning of March.
And,
uh,
yeah,
like horrible,
horrible,
like I wish like I actually had,
I think that's great for a kid to,
um,
I think it's great for him to meet a lot of people,
you know,
like,
um,
like we've had a lot of people come over the first year of my daughter's life
and um,
so like when people come over,
she's not really like,
oh my God,
who's that?
It doesn't fuck with their universe.
And then to get them,
you know,
to talk to the adults or speak publicly is something,
I think that's a huge,
that's something I wish,
you know,
I was so fucking shy.
I almost feel like someone needed to do that to kind of nudge me out.
But if they did,
I probably wouldn't have been as fucked up.
I would've,
I would've just been some guy,
you know,
and it's funny the way up to management at this point and he's only in first
grade and one's like,
oh,
so he must be the class clown and classical.
No,
he's not.
I go,
that's why he could be a good comic.
He's not the guy.
Get away.
Look at me over here because those guys are never good.
Yeah,
there's a lot of hacks in elementary,
you know,
like fart jokes and those guys that tried to do comedy light or a terrible,
then it's terrible that you know,
you want the quiet guy that's just sitting back and observing everything and
remembering it and writing it down.
You don't want the guy jumping on the desk.
That's the guy.
He's going to be a hack.
He's going to do it.
You're the guy who ended up meeting at your show later and he's just like,
dude,
I was funnier than you.
I should have done this shit.
And you're like,
well go,
go do it.
Or if he does stand up,
he's the guy who does the arms thing at the end where to go behind a comic and
work the arms.
How about great.
Was that though the first time you saw it?
It was hilarious.
It was the greatest thing ever.
Cause I saw I had an itch down my crotch and they'd have some hot girl and she'd
have to go.
I know,
you know,
one of the,
uh,
one of the most misunderstood comedians of all time,
I believe is Gallagher because everybody looks at him like he was this fucking
guy smashing all this shit.
He was making fun of advertising.
That's what that bit was,
right?
Sledge dramatic.
What the hell is it?
And it didn't work,
but it was all this visual stuff.
But so many people took it at face value.
They just wanted to go like,
Oh
God,
we're going to get like cottage cheese all in orange juice all over.
They'd ever got the bid.
And what killed me is if you watched the beginning of his act,
he had some really,
really good material,
clever material.
I'm at one time Patrice rest,
his soul was talking to him on the opie and Anthony Show and he was saying how,
um,
you know,
you need to pick a path.
You know,
it was great.
You get you,
they're going to do this Carlin stuff or you're going to be the guys smashing
shit.
And like he just wasn't able to convey it in a way.
And I remember listening to it.
I was driving,
I was listening to on the radio.
I was just going like,
yes,
exactly.
He had that fucking bit where he sat down in the,
in the school desk and he did this whole bit where he starts talking about how
weird words are spelled in our life and our,
uh,
English language.
He started with the word.
I just remember him going like something like,
uh,
I ended up going to like it,
like heard and then you point here,
is this a bird?
No.
Beard,
B.
A R D.
Neat.
When you did the whole fucking thing and then the end,
he got back to the word that he started with and then he just does this,
it just all in circles.
And that's why he didn't go to school.
It's like fucking great bit.
Yeah.
For some reason he had to be sitting at a school desk when he did it.
So everybody starts going,
always a prop guy.
I Dunno.
No,
I remember he used to do his standup.
I remember seeing,
I like Tom has a,
Katie was on roller skates right then.
They do a thing where it was like a giant couch and he put a trampoline in it
and shit and like every,
so everybody would remember that.
Right.
But in the middle of all that,
he had this,
no.
Yeah,
I know he did.
I remember at the end he would,
but yeah,
he was almost like Carlin back in a day,
like a good smart material.
I was funny.
Yeah.
But yeah,
you come out on a giant fucking tricycle and then,
and then he wanted of it gets lost,
the grows and then he retires and he sells his act.
It was brother Gallagher to Gallagher to goes out.
He starts making a fortune
and then gala gets jealous.
She goes,
wait a minute,
now I want my act back.
He was like,
no,
you sold it to me.
And then they had to go to court and now Gallica too can't do it anymore.
So get the real gile goes back out there.
Yeah,
he,
he told them to do it when he couldn't tell.
I think I've heard so many stories and then he told him to stop doing it.
I just remember when that came when Gallagher too came to Boston.
It was the funniest fucking thing cause like Gallagher to to the layman sounded
like,
oh he wrote a new hour,
you know what I mean?
Like Ghostbusters,
Ghostbusters part to Gallagher Gallagher part too.
Right.
So he would go up there and it would be like,
it would,
it wouldn't take any more than three or four minutes.
Like right out of the gate.
It's like why does his voice sound so weird?
Cause he kind of looked like if you sat in the back and then people just start
what within four formats.
It's like,
Dude,
this isn't Gallagher.
Who the fuck is this?
And then this murmur would start and he that could fucking guy wouldn't even
address it and he would stay up there for an hour as people going like,
who the fuck is this guy?
Um,
I only watched the first 10 minutes.
I had to run out and go do a spot.
But the tension in the room,
that was back then where you could actually just do 40 member,
45 was closing just to 45 minutes somehow.
Then it became like an hour.
I could see I still do 45 a lot of times 45 on the road.
Sometimes I'm like I'm gonna,
I'm just going to do 45 if you're in like a club and they got a second share,
like a funny bone or something like that.
They've got a second show.
But even sometimes I just feel like doing 45 of 45th grade.
It's a blast.
Yeah.
Cause you look down when you've got your 35 years.
Like I got fucking ten one not that I want to get off stage where all my God,
this is going good.
I'm good.
45 minutes to close.
That's like having a beer in the afternoon.
He got nothing to do for the rest of the fucking day.
You know,
I'm jealous of his clean comics who get to like,
uh,
like I've heard Regan we'll do like afternoon,
like a matinee show and if I ever for some reason could find enough fucking
animals to show up for a matinee show for me,
I would stop working at night.
I would do a fucking two o'clock.
It's like in radio then,
but oop is still always telling me about like doing how afternoon drive is like
the greatest thing because you,
you know,
you,
you have a life like you can,
if you still want to go out that night,
you can and no matter how hard you hit it,
you can sleep cause you're not back on the air until like noon or one or two
o'clock in the afternoon.
But um,
I dunno when I get old in my whole crowd turns into like the blue hairs,
uh,
like I will have no fucking problem switching to being the man.
I'll fucking do it.
I'll do an afternoon show.
You can do,
you can do a five o'clock or five o'clock and seven 30 easily.
People want to go out early and are all the comedy clubs have switch this time.
So like seven o'clock,
seven 30 on a Friday for a show and seven o'clock on a Saturday.
You know what I hate the most?
I hate seven and 10.
Oh yeah.
I didn't know it was time in between to me.
Absolutely.
Way Too much time.
So you get the goody goody shown up at 10 and then you get the fucking meth
heads at seven then you get the meth heads at 10 I always think like,
what can we just do seven and nine seven,
nine just
exactly.
I'll do for my type 45 we'll get them in,
get them out.
Do you need me off so you can turn this room over?
Now,
that pet peeve of mine,
now we can pitch about clubs.
When the first show starts late,
it's like how did it start late?
You knew what to.
I can see the second show starting late because you,
you know somebody spilled some drinks and shit.
This is the physics right out of the fucking game.
Yeah.
You don't want to,
you want to put yourself in a hole right off the bat.
If it's seven o'clock there's no reason for it to start at seven 15 just started
at seven the has got to take the bullet.
Oh,
I took the bullet.
You took the bullet when your emcee and sorry,
this motherfucker's got to take it.
Does people still walking in and they're eating?
I it,
sorry man.
Yeah,
but you know,
these kids today,
they're all just say,
hey,
can we wait a minute?
Cause you know there's people still coming in.
I always go,
yeah,
don't worry.
Don't worry.
Right.
Oh my God.
The amount of fucking times.
That's the most amazing thing about that.
Richard Pryor special,
the one that he did down there at the terrorist theater,
the one he had the red shirt is he,
when he came out there was still people getting in this seats.
So anybody who's like a nerd for comedy,
like that situation is every situation that an opener gets put in,
he came out as a headliner on his own special dealt with that situation that
crushed.
Right.
I actually think,
you know,
just being a nerd fan of his,
that that put them in the zone because rather than going out and having to jump
into a bit going,
I am shooting as special and,
and here's my first idea.
He went out there and just fucking started riffing and like I think it just
after that it's the greatest special of all time.
And you don't think he had an opener that did time?
No,
he did what?
To whom I owe.
So we did.
He had,
did he have a band?
Um,
I used to know this right cause I remember uh,
Eddie Murphy on delirious had the bus boys from the movie 48 hours.
He had them open,
uh,
who the fuck did he have?
I used to know this.
It was like Gladys knight or something like that.
It was a singer.
Oh,
okay.
And they sang and everybody fucking went out to the bathroom afterwards.
And um,
yeah,
they were like,
Richard is still coming back to the seats.
He's like,
no,
I want to go out now.
Like he just was failing it and they just send them out there.
And I think that the chaos of it was what he kind of thrived in.
Um,
I dunno,
this is like some nerd shit,
but just the stuff that I've done it right about him.
Like when he was in like Vegas and everyone was sitting down,
he's supposed to wear clean and like thought that whole structured thing about
that he had like a fucking meltdown but then you get a more in that the,
the,
the little more chaos that was like,
like more of like his,
his kids' comfort zone was kind of chaos in a right.
It seems just from what I read it man obviously never met the guy.
I'm just um,
the worst was that,
I'm sure you went through it as member when you could still smoke in the comedy
clubs to first show Saturday was a no smoking show when they were always
uptight.
Yeah.
They were always a tight as,
they weren't a good crowd.
You knew if you just get through it,
that show the second show is going to be great cause they would have drinkers
and smokers and they're fun people and they'll just laugh.
But the first ones are fucking that.
They want to be home early.
They go out early and they don't want to put up with any smoke and they were
always fucking tight.
It felt like a job
coming out to just get this done.
Let's go to the comedy show.
Yeah,
we'll be home by nine 30 I remember when,
when,
when they used to fucking like by whole,
I don't know,
my first,
like my first eight years of stand up,
that would put me to 2000 right around 2000 they started to have the smoke free
stuff.
Like I had actually had like a smoker's cough a little bit.
I remember we,
I would wake up the next morning back when I had hair and I would get in the
shower and when the water would pour over me,
all the smoke that was in my hair,
I,
which I would just breathe it in and it smelled like I fought a fire.
So I started doing was I,
and I noticed I was getting a cough.
What I started doing was,
uh,
I'd come home after the shows and I would immediately take a shower and that was
just fucking throw my,
you know,
I was still living at home at the time,
eight years.
I know when I was in New York by then.
But like the first,
um,
three years when I was still living at home with my parents,
like I would just throw the clothes right in the fucking hamper and all of that
shit.
And uh,
can you maybe eyes would be like,
I'm going to be on stage.
My eyes were like burning
the funny bone and Saint Louis was always like,
it was,
it was like a smoke machine.
Like you were at a concert.
It was like Motley Crue starting off,
you know,
shout at the devil.
Yeah.
You couldn't see a foot in front of you.
The whole fucking room smoked and you're like,
Holy Shit.
And had to do like three shows on a Saturday.
I'm like,
this is brutal on my,
yeah.
Now you find him with doing like standup with,
uh,
cause then when I went back to New York,
I couldn't believe how many groans I was getting.
Like I was getting a lot of groans and in,
um,
or just like people like kind of look at each other.
Like,
what the fuck could just blows my mind that young people are like,
they,
they act like old people in clubs now and I feel like they are,
they're like,
I dunno like it cause they grew up on social media.
Like you just saying shit,
like you're going to get in trouble.
How have you found,
it seems like you think the New York scenes great.
Like I'm out of it.
I just went back for a couple of days and I think I was a little weirded out by
some of the,
uh,
the people that are you finding it that it's there because you've been there,
like you could sort of just because you're there every fucking night,
like you don't notice a change?
Yeah,
I don't see,
I don't see a change in too much.
I mean,
I don't see a change in out here either.
When I do sets at the comedy store and Improv,
I could pretty much do the same set.
I'm really feel it.
Um,
I don't know where you did and,
but I,
you know,
I know it like a deer stand or New York comedy club.
They just come in to laugh and there's not really,
no one's really gone,
man,
that crowd sucks.
That's so uptight.
And so we're not getting that at all.
So you know what it was.
I live out here now,
so I'm comfortable,
comfortable out here.
So I feel like la crowds are better than New York and it's just because I'm
living out here and I'm just used to it.
I think that that's what it is.
Why always hated La Crowds.
When I used to come out 10 15 years ago,
I would,
you know,
it was like,
what?
Why is this guy so angry on stage?
I just didn't get it.
You know what I mean?
I wasn't physical,
I wasn't smiling all the time and shit.
I'm like,
man,
these crowds are rough.
And then it turned,
I don't know,
like maybe seven,
eight years ago where it just,
you could do whatever you want and the comics were dirty and edgy and they
laughed at because the laugh factory for so long,
this is such a weird thing to say.
It was too happy a place.
It was too well lit,
you know?
And then I saw that thing in the background look like the Warner brothers and
that's all folks will take a big fucking cartoon.
So I'd get in there and you could see the whole fucking Rome and then I just got
like self conscious when I would go on that stage being like just if you said
anything fucked up.
But now I love the club.
Um,
it definitely was,
I,
I tried to stay away from that club because I knew I never did well on there.
Do you think that like,
uh,
there's going to be a backlash to this?
Like a sort of like,
I dunno cause I'm not saying everything that people get offended by is,
is wrong because that's not accurate.
But um,
the overreaction in this,
this like I'm kind of thinking how every generation rebels against the other
generation.
The previous,
I'm kind of thinking like the next group of,
of young kids coming up.
I guess maybe it's wishful thinking.
I'm hoping that they're going to be more like the people I knew in the seventies
and eighties.
I don't think so because this generation,
the young ones now,
they don't drink,
they don't do drugs.
They might smoke a little pot.
They're not like promiscuous,
like the last generation before that where they were,
you know,
having sex early and getting no one 19 year old kids are not going in the woods
and Drinkin you know what I mean?
To not get high and not doing mushrooms like we did.
I was,
I was smoking pot at 12 years old.
I was drinking and smoking cigarettes.
When you would hide the beers that you were all excited,
like you still,
everybody was like,
okay,
just steal like three beers from you dad.
I'll still three bubba and he put together like this,
this stash.
And then you'd go and you'd bury him in the fucking woods member when you would
go out there.
It'd be so fucking cold that they froze,
froze.
And then you'd have to fucking just sit there and just slowly,
SIF is solely said that you wouldn't even be getting drunk interviews,
giant ice of fucking beer or they'd get skunked.
Uh,
if you left them out there too long,
even as every weekend I was like,
you'd go to the woods,
you get as fucked up as you possibly could and then the cops would show up every
fucking weekend.
Chase you are there and everyone to leap in their cars wasted.
I mean there has to be a happy medium between that and what the fuck is going
on.
Uh,
I like how I'm talking about this.
Like I know what kids are doing.
They're also doing like fucking ecstasy and meth and shit.
It is pretty nuts.
Yeah.
But I,
I seriously like the,
they're not,
they're not output,
you know,
like drinking and stuff like that.
I got a bunch of nieces and nephews and their friends and stuff like I see it
and none of them doing anything.
Don't touch alcohol.
They don't smoke.
They're not even in the woman.
I would
you do if there was a flat screen TV in your house,
you know,
and these kids,
a lot of people get like a couple of them.
This is like a fucking TV and like every major room in their house.
You can go online,
talk to people,
play in video games.
You can watch porn on your right,
on your phone.
Yeah.
You could watch plane.
You watch a scene.
A fucked up it is that you can just watch footage of a plane crashing.
Nobody knew what the fuck that look like when we were growing.
He had to go to like can,
there's some war footage,
but the,
you can just watch you literally see anything.
What does it look like when a guy jumps off the building?
He hits the pavement.
What does that look like?
I don't know what that website is because I was never into the death shit.
Uh,
but you,
you know,
I remember some of the fucking comics I was came up with when,
when all that Isis Shit,
when they was saw in people's fucking heads off,
they would go on and watch it and then they would come in like,
Oh God,
it was so fucked up.
It's like,
why would you do that?
Like I actually know,
like I did a bit one time about being on fire,
screaming and blah,
blah blah,
blah blah.
And a buddy of mine,
it's comic I knew,
told me.
He goes,
that's actually not the noise people make when they get burned to death.
And he started imitating the noise.
It was even creepier.
And I'm like,
how the fuck do you know that?
And he goes,
ah,
you know,
I've watched some pretty dark shit.
It's like you fucking,
somebody got burned to death and you,
you sat and fucking watched it.
I don't know.
I saw one isis beheading video.
My brother sent it to me and he's like,
don't worry,
it's not what it is.
It's a joke at the end.
Just watch it through the end just to mess with my hall and I,
and it was,
it's still,
that was like 15 years ago,
10 years ago.
I still can't get out of my mind.
I never watched that stuff.
I don't want to want to see anybody get hit by a car.
I don't want to see any of that shit.
They live if they live.
It's just kind of,
yeah,
you want to,
I like the happy medium.
If you can't handle the car is somebody getting gored by a bull because it's
literally like,
the only thing cartoon does not exaggerate is how high you go into the air.
When it bull hits you,
I'll fuck,
I don't have my phone and look my phone,
this guy fucking,
this dude's running.
And he's uh,
he said,
you know,
it was fucking idiot.
He's in the ring with a bunch of other guys.
As bunch of bowls run around and he didn't have his head on the swivel.
He gets fucking shut up in the air and the ball takes off and the guy goes into
like a fetal position and then everybody comes and saves him and now he's
running like looking back to see if the bulls come in.
And as he's looking back,
another bull comes to the
guy again.
Yeah.
It was just like if he was an NFL player,
he's like,
he was on special teams as some shit in his,
uh,
his career's going to be over.
I do have to read a little bit of advertising here,
but um,
uh,
I can't even say how great it is to see.
I don't ever get to see it now that I became a big phony out here in Hollywood.
Well,
you know,
when you've got a kid too,
man,
it's a whole other,
yeah.
You know this,
this weekend is,
is my daughter's first birthday.
First Birthday.
Wow.
I'm baking my first cake and my wife and invited all these people.
There's going to be all these kids there,
but what,
we're going to have a cool,
like,
it's like adult food,
right?
You know,
if you want some whiskey or something like that,
whatever,
you know,
if the other spouse is cool,
we'll let you drive.
It's fine.
And then we got all this cool shit with the kids.
I never call it gift bag is is like this fucking bag of like gummy bears and
just,
I don't know,
kids love gummy bears.
Right?
You know,
10 years ago you'd never thought you'd be baking a cake.
But my theory,
whenever
you think like,
I don't know if I could do this,
this is kind of what you do for the kid.
If there's a kid involved,
do you get a pass?
Oh yeah,
no.
My,
my,
my wife said to me,
she's going like,
I don't know,
it's gonna be all these people because the recipe,
I had this for like a,
like a two layer cake and then she may want to make it three and then she's just
like,
well,
you know,
you could just go to the grocery store and do the Dunkin Hines thing.
And I was like,
no,
I'm not fucking doing that.
All right.
I'm doing this every year.
Like this is one of these things that you,
you got to have on the,
on the resume for like when your kid gets old,
it'd be like,
what kind of dad?
What kind of dad?
Which my dad made me a cake every year.
I got to at least have that because I'm a fucking lunatic and I know I'm going
to snap.
Well,
my son has gone a little person to be around.
I'm an asshole so I at least got to come through with a cake,
right?
No,
you have to document everything too because they don't believe you.
That's the advice I got from other parents.
Take pictures because they're not going to believe that you took them to
Disneyland every year and all those and you did all the shit with them.
So whenever I take my son anywhere and event,
I take a picture.
So I go,
hey motherfucker,
this is what I did at five.
This is what I did at six.
Look what I did.
Dan Marino told me.
Dot.
Moreno told me one time he came out to Mike show and I ain't even get to see how
he gets to him.
Yeah,
he'd tell me,
he seems,
Hey,
Dan Marino was out when I was in Fort Lauderdale.
It's like,
fuck,
I want to love if he came back.
He's such a humble guy.
Oh,
he's great.
He's funny.
He's awesome,
man.
I got to tell them what I've been wanting to tell him forever.
I was like,
dude,
if you play today in your prime with these rules of coverage,
you would throw for 6,000 yards without a problem every season,
and he's,
ah man,
I appreciate that.
Now he knows he still loves to show off his arm.
He loves to just go,
let me just show you.
When they did those rock and jock things under Superbowl,
those rappers,
you know like qtip or something and he's firing at him.
Then did you see to see us?
He must've watched Dan Marino football life.
Phenomenal was arm goes up,
ball comes out.
It still looked like when,
when they were just showing him throwing the ball,
it looked like they sped up the film.
That's like a,
it's like a fucking a viper.
You can't even see it.
It just fucking goes up in the burnout and it's a tight spiral.
Um,
that's funny.
Listen Motherfucker,
I took it here.
You're going to say he taught so just take document and take pictures the whole
time.
We didn't do anything dad.
I'm already worried that uh,
when they go through that period where inevitably they hate you because they
think it gets to the kid gets to a point where they know enough shit that they
think they're ready to live on their own.
That comes around like what?
1112,
13 and then you just got,
then you just got to wait to the like 26 I think.
And then they kind of like,
oh wait a minute.
You know,
it's so rough.
So it seems like it's like a rough 15 years.
Let me read this post.
Stop doing this doctor Phil.
Shit.
All right.
Oh me undies.
Everybody owe me undies.
Me undies.
Mother,
fuck,
I took you here to me,
undies,
me undies.
I opened your fucking first beer.
All right,
me and you want to look good and your underwear and be comfortable.
Right?
But that perfect balance is hard to find.
Doubts.
Sacrifice the comfort.
Why would you do that?
Talk about why me undies is the best underwear you will ever own.
Well it's free.
They send it to me,
you know,
so I'll wear it.
Fill out good at fills on my balls and then I'll tell you guys how great it is.
It is.
I've got to tell you,
it is pretty amazing.
And um,
it's got a superhero vibe to it.
So I always feel a little stronger when I wear it.
Does that contractually fill my obligation there monies will be the most
comfortable pair of underwear you will ever own.
Made from sustainably sourced natural soft fabric that is three times softer
than cotton.
Ultimate feel good undies for what you want to feel.
Uh,
so when for when you want to feel naked,
what ultimate feel good undies.
So when you want to feel naked,
not be naked.
All right,
sentence always trips me up.
100% satisfaction guaranteed.
They're guaranteed.
You will love your undies or your money back right now.
Uh,
me undies has an exclusive opera from my listeners.
Get 20% off your first pair and the F and free shipping and me unease is so sure
you will love this.
Their underwear,
they even offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
This is the point,
the coffee when I want to start fucking crying because I'm so bad at reading out
loud and I still have like another three paragraphs.
All right,
you order a pair and if you don't love your first pair,
get a full refund.
There's,
this is a no brainer,
20% off free shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
What are you waiting for to get you 20% off free shipping and their 100%
satisfaction guarantee.
You can get the best and softest underwear you will ever own.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] this is a limited time opera,
so what are you waiting for?
Start wearing the best underwear of your life.
It changed my life evidently according to the copy.
Yeah.
If I wasn't wearing these,
I wouldn't have had Jim Florentine on here promoting his book.
Everybody's awful except for you available now.
That's like the joke within a joke.
Uh,
the ad within an ad,
um,
sat wearing the best underwear of your life.
It changed my life.
It's time to let me undies change yours.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr right now.
All right,
let's wrap this up.
I want to get Jim Florentine Florentine Florentine Florentines,
um,
NFL picks for this weekend.
Patriots.
Jags,
you already picked a pats that,
let's talk about the eagles and the vikings.
Two teens that have never won a Superbowl.
Neither the Jaguar three out of 14 had not won a Superbowl.
That's
a tough one.
This is going to be,
you know,
cause the two backup quarterbacks and their,
um,
Minnesota has got a good deal.
You don't know what nick falls is going to show up,
right?
Um,
I'm going to go,
I'm going to go Philly.
You're going to go Philly.
I'm going to go fill at home Philly at home fucking ends.
All that excite that in Minnesota.
Yeah,
I think so.
And the city of brotherly say should have lost that New Orleans game.
They should have,
you know,
what did I lose it?
And then New Orleans,
fuck the whole thing up.
So yeah,
it was,
imagine if you are a die hard saints fan
and that would be like,
that would literally be like if you fucking,
if you did a fucking standup special,
you had the greatest special of all fucking time.
And then right at the end of your special,
you went to put the mic and the mic stand is somehow you did like a fucking face
plant.
I'm trying to think like what you could do.
Like you did it or maybe,
oh,
there was no audio.
Oh yes,
it was wave.
No,
but you'd have to go and somehow you,
you fucked up.
Okay.
Yeah.
No,
the end.
You just go,
I like fucking kids.
And you'd take a dick out and start jerking off.
Maybe it's not that,
that and that.
Yeah.
So I think,
yeah,
the eagles maybe a field goal though when it,
when a buyer for it and it'll be Philly and patriots and patriots,
you know.
Okay.
31 20 something like that.
I like that.
I'm hoping the Patriots win.
And you just look at the quarterback.
So that's where you've got a dog who has a better defense eagles or a vikings?
The Vikings,
I kind of want the vikings are on the road.
They got an a better defense and then you know,
they got a backup,
but he's the guy at this point.
Yeah.
Case Kanombe that's what's making me feel old now is the names of quarterback
case Carson.
It's just like our generation is gone that there's no,
Jim says no bills.
No,
no,
not anymore.
There's no Steve.
Remember Steve?
No.
Steve to Berg anymore.
Steve Debars,
the Marino,
you know Stevie on Yo like I left is like Jay,
uh,
Yo Yo Guy Jake.
Oh,
Jay Cutler.
Jake's not in my field.
Goal kickers.
Cody.
I,
I've never,
there was never a coating on the dolphins till last year.
Oh,
they love to see names that old.
Everybody born in the 90s seem to have like a c name.
It started with Clemens.
Oh no,
he,
he named everything with a k.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
the Cody.
But like it was that.
All right,
so you'll pick it up.
I'm going to say,
I'm hoping the Patriots win and then I have no idea.
Ah,
such a fucking hard when I would actually say the vikings go in and break the
eagles heart,
but the football gods smiled on him last week.
Am I going to go against the Vikings again this week?
I can't do that because then if they win,
I'll have to go against them again if the Patriots win and then I'll be jinx in
my own team.
So do I pick it up?
Fuck that.
And I don't think there's going to be a big home field advantage of the vikings
going into soup bowl.
A lot of those are corporate tickets and it doesn't,
the Patriots can play anywhere,
so it doesn't matter.
My,
I think,
uh,
that's a tough one.
That's the game.
Vikings Eagles is a game that's going to be a good one.
I e.
I'm going to say Vikings on pic.
No,
you took the eagles.
I'll take the vikings.
Fuck it.
Yeah.
I just think the old nick foals is going to show up.
Old Nick foals shows up.
But both of those fucking teams,
both those franchises,
the football gods love to fucking yank the rug out from underneath.
I know.
I think there's a chance to stadium I collapsed on the bowling team.
Either way.
It's going to be great,
Jim.
So great to see it.
So awesome.
They have you on the podcast and once again,
everybody is awful except you is available now for preorder preorders February
20th and February 20th.
You can get it on Amazon,
Barnes and noble into,
to quote Jim Florentine,
all of that shit.
You'll be able to get it,
uh,
really happy for you,
buddy.
Continuous success and,
uh,
hope to run into you in New York.
All right.
Thanks man.